Remember that this is a program that really
wouldn't exist without your support.
And the primary source of that support comes
through Web site memberships.
You can read all about it and sign up in under
a minute at join Pacman dot com.
We do have a really great discussion forum
with more than I think we're we're close to
22 or 23000 of our viewers are subscribed
to our sub Reddit.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com slash.
Read it.
There are a number of interesting posts from
our viewers, a couple of which I want to highlight.
One user who goes by the name stressed, Matt
said, Would the cutting of the Postal Service
hurt Republicans?
We know that Democrats are more likely to
vote absentee, while Republicans are more
likely to vote in person.
But Republicans are more likely to live in
rural areas.
Rural areas are the ones are the areas that
actually need a functioning postal service
the most.
So given the delays, would it be more likely
for a rural voter to not have their ballot
delivered on time compared to someone in a
city?
Well, you have to compare that, which I'm
sure you're right about.
You have to compare that to the disproportionate
number of Biden supporters planning to vote
by mail, and that already accounts for the
urban rural divide.
So it's it's ultimately a math problem.
My instinct my instinct is that still accounting
for the urban rural divide, it is still Joe
Biden who's worse off if the Postal Service
fails to deliver absentee ballot.
That's my instinct.
But ultimately, it is an empirical question
with some unknowns.
And we'd have to think about whether we can
actually gather all the data.
We need to answer that.
Another post from the sub Reddit by user Kay
Anello, 17, who says, Can we all just take
a moment to recognize the fact that David
is now less than 10000 subscribers shy of
one million?
It is not even 10000.
In fact, let me take a look.
While we're while we're talking here, we are
now only 7000 subscribers, shy of one million
on YouTube.
It's actually looking like we're going to
hit the million during our vacation week,
which, you know, if five years ago you said
you're going to hit a million subscribers
in 2020, but you'll be on vacation.
I would have said there's no way you could
know that.
And it does look like that's the way it's
going to be.
But we've got some great videos and a bunch
of great congratulatory messages from some
of our friends, many of whom you will recognize
plan for when we do hit one million subscribers.
So, yes, we are only 7000 subscribers away.
Help us.
Once we get to a million, I think things are
going to get very, very crazy in a number
of different ways.
YouTube dot com slash The David Pakman Show.
And of course, join the discussion on The
David Pakman Show sub Reddit at David Pakman
dot com slash our EDI's DHT.